[Musique]
montréalais et montréalaises
vous reconnaissez ce bâtiment pendant
des années lusine canada mantegna servi
à transformer leurs gens malte à
l'abandon depuis plus de 30 ans le
bâtiment est aujourd'hui un emblème du
quartier saint-henri c'est le vestige de
l'histoire l'histoire industrielle qui
est très important de la ici noam signer
je veux lui donner une seconde vie il
veut notamment construire des logements
sociaux et familiaux dans l'ancien
complexe et ses gigantesques silo
l'obtention des permis et un changement
de zonage freine les ardeurs du
développeur immobilier
mais le temps presse le bâtiment est
très détériorée il faut réagir assez
vite
le dossier est complexe plusieurs
acteurs sont impliqués et tous se
renvoie la balle la valeur patrimoniale
elle est affirmé par tout le monde mais
c'est comme si personne ne voulait
vraiment l'assumer pleinement à 10 ans b
vient de vert-le-petit moyens il faut
complètement moi je crois qu'on trouve
une solution d'esi nous tous collaboré
là c'est nous tous mettre ensemble et
trouver la façon de aller en avant le
cas de la mort du co est loin d'être
unique un autre exemple celui du silo
élévateur numéro 5 construit au tournant
du xxème siècle il se dégrade depuis des
décennies on voit bien que l'on joue sur
deux registres sont dits oui ça de sa
valeur patrimoniale mon père a pas les
moyens d'abord de protéger efficacement
grâce ou de trouver un usage chaque
dossier est différent dans d'autres cas
des promoteurs négligent volontairement
le bâtiment
avec le temps la démolition devient
inévitable car ce qui les intéresse
c'est le terrain et puis il ya la
stratégie du façadisme seule la façade
d'un bâtiment reste en place et on
construit derrière au lieu d'être une
exception c'est devenu une habitude
dans son plus récent rapport le conseil
du patrimoine de montréal dénonce cette
pratique de plus en plus courante
phénomène qui cache souvent la
densification urbaine selon pieter
jacobs la densification
pour le se faire tout en faisant la
conservation de patrons - ils sont mises
en valeur mais si il est fait avec soin
on peut pas dire une chose de façon
contraire il faut y recourir six
secteurs de grande valeur patrimoniale
c'est par là qu'on doit fait de la
densification il faut la concertation de
tous les gouvernements selon lui mais il
ya peut-être un peu d'espoir québec
dévoilera cette toute première politique
nationale d'architecturé et
d'aménagement du territoire en 2022 quel
important donnera-t-on au patrimoine
québécois les experts sont impatients de
le savoir ici qui me permettra au canada
montréal